uh just  a bit of fun and games there just  magnus magnus got a sneaky threat he  wants to offer a trade of rooks  and force those rooks off the board  which would be a hundred percent draw  yeah i mean trying to win this position  against the best in-game player of all  time  it's a little tricky right it's a big  struggle it's an uphill struggle so  definitely  okay the blackrook trying to get active  but white shuts that down again with his  bishop and no progress to be to be made  whatever black tries white just says no  okay hang on you could be a bit sneaky  right could you offer up one pawn you  could push the a pawn one square and  your whole idea is just to break could  have been captured it could be a draw  it's a draw yes there could be okay we  do see a result magnus is through to the  finals he is  after only three games in this  semi-final as well magnus winning game  one and game two is ready for the first  final in the mild water champions  chester 2020